and i i think it's a good example of
sometimes you can find a real gap in the
market in
in something that is like very niche
like it would never become
a billion dollar company obviously
[Music]
leor grossman thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders welcome
thank you thank you for having me thank
you very very much for being here all
the way from sunny california
to uh the dark and stormy tel aviv but
you know it's interchanging and both
places have wonderful weather lior
an expert in open source i think you
founded like five or six companies
in this in this world and it's and it's
it's unbelievable
not all of them in this world but but i
know that that's what open base is about
and some of the others like wiki want
and
and something like that but i i would
love to first hear about your journey
hear about who you are
starting all the way back when you built
your own computer within your car and i
have to say
that when i buy a car and the first
thing that i look at is the multimedia
screen and you actually
built one for yourself so tell me about
that
right that's that's a crazy story
actually so
um my first car it was a blue
pejo 106. you know kind of like
i think it was like the 97 model and
back then in the days like it's a really
old car it didn't have any
like multimedia system and being the
computer geek that i am
i decided to do something about it so i
ended up
actually building a personal computer
that sits
in the trunk of the car uh it's it it's
connected like through
cables all that run all through the car
and i ordered uh a touchscreen
touchscreen was like an in a thing like
back then like in the early 2000s so
i actually had to order one from ebay
uh got it all the way built it into the
dashboard of the car
and basically every time i would start
the car
uh it would start a personal computer
sitting in the trunk
it would have multimedia it would have
music it would have
wi-fi everything uh this was kind of a
very crazy hobby project i would say
unbelievable i
i love those types of projects it's it's
really
it's really amazing and tell me a little
bit about your startup journey
you i know that you are a team leader in
one of the elite units in the idf and
then you go and you go and you build
a massive a portfolio of companies each
of them
in a different space all of them making
a huge impact
walk me through some of them before we
reach open base and the open source
industry
uh sure so i've been
i would say a late bloomer as
entrepreneur
so i think you know uh
i would say my focus has been mostly on
entrepreneurship for the past decade or
so but
you know god i'm old um
so basically i got into entrepreneurship
by building my
own software development firm so
around 2007 i started my own
software development firm it was called
open base i've been working
with wonderful wonderful uh clients most
of them small startups
and i help them get to market uh with
their products
and this has revealed the world of
entrepreneurship to me in the world of
startups and how fascinating it is and
the kind of like challenges
they had around product around go to
market around uncertainty
and that's how i kind of like got
enchanted and
and um got into this world of startups
uh
so i would say in the past decade i
probably build in
one capacity or another probably build
a dozen products at the very least maybe
even more
uh some of them were kind of like you
know entirely bootstrap
most of them honestly you know was
complete failure
i think you know that's part of the
process uh
some of them were uh more successful
uh a couple of them were actually you
know have
came to become profitable businesses uh
they are still active and you know
they generate revenue they have a lot of
happy users and
i'm very proud but i think it's all part
of the journey kind of like being
able to fail and learn from your mistake
and kind of like not repeat the same
mistake uh
twice right and improve as an
entrepreneur over time so previously
i built um book authority
which is a basically a recommendation
website uh for books if you will
it's like goodreads but we base our
recommendations
based on experts like people like elon
musk people like jeff bezos
uh recommended books and we highlight
the most recommended books on our
platform uh
so um that's book authority it has you
know quite a lot of correction
uh i think almost a million users a
month
wow a lot of recommendations a lot of
books sold
that's yeah that's that's a great great
great example of like dog fooding
because i set out to build book
authority to solve my own problem i was
looking for great books to read
and i was sifting through like articles
on forbes and inc
uh eventually you know i couldn't find
you know that
you know the most recommended book so i
ended up like building this database
i love came to be a book authority i
just love it
that type of stuff inspires me just like
what you did with it with the pcr for
the car
my father who's at google he didn't ever
have time to listen to articles and he
had a pipeline of
hundreds if not thousands of articles
and he said why can't the phone read
those out to me
with you know push of a button or bite
with the assistant so he developed an
app within google that is now used by
a lot of people around the world that
that reads
articles for busy people as they're
driving as if it's a podcast but
i digress but that is the exact type of
entrepreneurship and innovation that
really inspires me
tell me a little bit about wiki wand and
darkness because those are also two
fascinating adventures that i'd love to
learn more about
yeah so uh darkness um
is is an interesting example of um
i would say a gap in the market so
nowadays
you would notice like you know today a
lot of websites and apps offer
uh dark themes so you would have it like
you know on youtube and you would have
it in facebook more recently
and now i think you know you have it in
google in beta basically your search
base in it rtm
uh but i started darkness you know a few
years ago
and at this time i i knew how much i
love dark themes and then kind of like
you know from my other products
i kind of realized a lot of other people
around the world love the concept of
like
browsing websites with dark teams people
you know sometimes they're like
night owls they like working at night a
bright screen is like very glaring it's
not fun to use and also you have this
coolness factor about like
working uh with a dark theme uh so i
decided to build darkness darkness is an
extension
for chrome that allows you um
to convert to transform i think about
like 20 websites
uh to be dark themed and we support like
google
facebook youtube like many other
websites
and we had quite a lot of success we
were actually featured in chrome web
store
uh we got a lot of downloads the product
itself is kind of dual in that like
it is an open source product so you can
use the open source version
download it for free get like all the
features
get it installed on your computer or you
can download it from
uh chrome web store where it's a a
freemium product in a way where you have
the basic
feature set but if you want to get like
the full possibility
basically get access to like 20
different websites seven different
themes
uh you pay basically that's like a micro
payment we don't charge
99 an hour for a chrome extension
obviously but the nice thing about it
is that we had you know tens of
thousands of paying customers for
darkness
so it has become quite a success
and i i think it's a good example of
sometimes you can find a real gap in the
market in
in something that is like very niche
like it would never become
a billion dollar company obviously but i
ended up like solving my arm problem
and on the way solving the problem
for hundreds of thousands of other
people around the world
unbelievable it's great i i remember
when one of the developers and
i i was also at 8200 and i remember the
day that one of our developers his name
is gilad
he brought it into the unit a dark theme
for a lot of the applications and i
remember everybody was going crazy
for some reason engineers and developers
love dark themes
and now it's actually become a comment i
think that ios
launched their dark themes recently but
but you know i can see that i can see i
love that idea of solving your own
problems again and what about wiki one
what is that about
so wiki one i started wiki one back in
um
uh it was 2013. i started it with saul
wilf
which is an amazing amazing serial
investor
one of the best angel investors in
israel i think
and the idea behind wiki one was that
again there is this huge gap in the
market so you have wikipedia
wikipedia is one of the top 10 websites
on the internet in terms of like usage
you have like hundreds of
like uh tens of billions of users uh
using weak using wikipedia all the time
and the funny thing about wikipedia
is that it's so frequently used but it
is a product that
hasn't evolved for the past decade it
hasn't evolved at all in terms of like
the user experience
the usability the feature set it's still
the same old wikipedia
and we're all like very frustrated by
that so we decided to basically
rebuild wikipedia for the modern user
right so like you would get the same
content that you get on wikipedia
but with better readability with better
search better discovery
uh power features customizability one of
the things we had early on it wasn't
that popular back in the days uh
but we had a dark theme so you could
customize uh
your interface and select the darting
for wiki one
and we ended up growing uh really really
uh
fast wiki one we ended up winning the
uh 2015 webby award for the best user
experience on the internet
yeah yeah the webby award and yeah this
is like thanks to the amazing team
like we have uh sar and elon and tom are
a designer
like you know the team world small team
kind of like doing amazing work around
like buildings product it has become a
huge success we have
over um 10 million people using a week
you want every month right now it's a
profitable business
um yeah it's a pleasure to use honestly
you know
more that i'm proud like you know uh
probably with attraction i'm proud that
you know it's a product that i enjoy
use and we know so many people enjoy
using wiki one
wow leor we'll get to the y combinator
experience and open base and
how you're solving a pretty big problem
for developers with with
so many open source opportunities but i
have to
gauge your your passion for solving
problems with
with products sometimes their niche
sometimes they're not so niche but what
is it about solving problems with great
people that really gets you excited
because
you've done it so much you've been
successful in almost all of them which
is incredible
but what what what do you do why do you
do that
why not just go start a billion dollar
company 10 years ago
uh i i think it's about like in a way
it's a lot about the journey of
entrepreneur and i wouldn't say you know
i built a lot of failures and like
there's always this
uh i would say survivor
survivorship by us or like you learn
about the successes but i could fill up
an episode of an hour about like all the
products that i built
and were never successful and i think
it's important for other entrepreneurs
to hear about it
uh because it's not always like sunny
and roses and a lot of things that i've
built were like down
downright failure and some of them were
like you know a mild success and some of
them
like were a bigger success and that's
part of the journey
uh but i'm kind of like digressing um
i i think for me uh building products or
like creating
is part of like my invoice invocation
this is not a job this is not even a
hobby a hobby i
i recall even when i was younger before
i got into
uh you know programming before i got
into entrepreneurship before i had the
skills
i always loved creative things whether
like you know drawing schemes or coming
up with inventions and stuff like that
so
for me that's not even a choice i think
that's
just the way i'm worried i don't see
myself doing anything else by you know
but creating but building products i
i just love that so y combinator open
base
solving a problem in the open source
space before we even talk about open
base
what is open source what is open source
and why is it
a growing field today
so open open source is kind of like an
amazing phenomena i would say in
software development
so uh i've been developing software for
a while probably since i was 10 and
software development like you know two
decades ago was
very different from today so two decades
ago
if you were to develop a complicated
rich piece of software
you had to develop every little piece
yourself
right and that means like you have a
product you have a tooltip you have it
so like a dialogue that you want to
display you want to handle
text manipulation all of these as a
developer as a company you had to
develop yourself
and the open source movement was kind of
revolutionary
in that other developers uh
developers around the world started work
working collaboratively with other
developers
and sharing their source code what
they've built with other developers
so now as a developer you can tap to the
collective knowledge collective power
of millions of other developers around
the world and when you build software
nowadays
actually the statistics are are
astounding so
uh more than 50 of a modern app
modern product modern website is
comprised of
open source code and less than 50
is actually built by that like person or
company
so i think the the wonderful thing about
open source is
that it allows company to focus on their
core competency on their product
while utilizing you know the collective
power of open source
so they don't have to reinvent the wheel
they don't have to keep like building
this dialogue
and this tax parsing and this like those
accounting functions
because other people have done this so
in a way they're standing on the
shoulders of giants
right now that makes a lot of sense so
what is the opportunity that you
that you realize in that in that gap
because you know as a developer
when i when i write and i i'm actually
surprised that it's not more than 50
because when i go into for an
application if it's if it's you know
a relatively simple application i think
maybe 80 of the code that
that i end up having is is importing a
code that much
smarter and more and more intelligent
engineers built
but what what is the gap that you found
in the market that that led you to start
open base
and have that a great opportunity
so i i found myself and developers
around me uh spending so much time
uh researching uh and evaluating open
source packages
and the thing is it wasn't an issue a
decade ago
because you only had a couple of
packages to do
every task whereas like today if you
look at the javascript ecosystem
you have almost 1.5 million
packages to choose from and that is that
is basically a jungle it's very hard to
choose the right package and even if you
know specifically what you're looking
for
you're looking for a specific task to
accomplish you have
hundreds of competing packages to choose
from
and this bets the question like how do
you choose the right one so
i was spending significant amount of
time each and every time i was looking
for an open source component
and then speaking to other developers i
i found that like you know
i'm not the only crazy one in general
developers
uh spend a lot of time sifting through
packages
and trying to find the best one for them
right and that's why i set out to build
open base uh that was may of
at 2019 last year um
and it's been quite a while right since
then yeah i can't even imagine
in a few sentences tell me about the y
combinator experience because that
by itself is you know one of the most
sought after experiences of any
entrepreneur
yeah so the y combinator experience has
been uh
amazing so we were actually the summer
2020 batch of y combinator that has been
the first fully remote batch of yc
i think the amazing thing about it was
seeing so many international founders
from all around the world like
and you know entrepreneurs are
entrepreneurs like the same people kind
of like struggle with the same problems
trying to achieve the same objectives so
this was an amazing experience
uh we had an amazing set of partners in
yc so like
help walk us through some of the growing
challenges of
uh of open base i think
they managed to pull off something like
this like this was the first
remote patch and they managed to execute
it so well
you know starting from like the office
hours and the day-to-day and the kind of
people
uh they kind of brought on uh to talk to
the startups and the demo day itself
then what they
you know was quite a feat because like
you have so many startups
pitching thousands of investors live on
zoom
getting all of that to work flawlessly
that is like
quite a feat so this has been once in a
lifetime experience that's for sure
i can't even imagine what are some
perhaps you know your two cents from
from that great summer that uh you would
take
with you moving forward or advice that
you would give to young entrepreneurs
uh so i think you know i
really paradoxically my biggest advice
or like take away from yc
is for example i was speaking with some
you know yc partners i was speaking with
what partner and getting this advice and
i was speaking to the other partner and
getting this other advice
and both of them are like you know super
qualified
highly successful entrepreneurs with a
lot of experience that is in like you
know hundreds of startups
so my advice would be take any advice
with a grain of salt because i think the
further you go
down um the rabbit hole of like building
a startup
the more specific your startup becomes
so you need to take any advice
within the right context and i think
you know generic advices are great when
you get started
but the more you go in the more you have
baggage the more you have specific
circumstances
you would need a very specific advice so
what i did
is kind of i utilize the advice to give
me perspective
and it was always like great because
that was like
a fresh perspective or like a way of
seeing things that i've never thought
about before
but it it doesn't mean that i take this
advice at power value it doesn't mean
that like you know
this person tells me yeah i think that
this
could work this couldn't i'm not taking
it at par value but whether i'm
synthesizing
all the data that i get i sort of like
build the map of the full gamut of all
the possibilities of the things that i
can do and i think this is something
that
russia was really useful kind of like
showing the full gamut of things that
you can do at
each stage but then as the ceo it's my
own responsibility to come up with a
choice you cannot outsource
your choices and your decisions to
someone else that gives you advice
100 lior i want to thank you for being
so generous with your time
and this was great before we leave i
have to ask you the most important
question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
wow so that's that's a great question
i um i would say
first is um i would say i'm ambitious
uh so i've always been and i think you
know
it's part of the thrill for me to pursue
uh
big goals um the other thing
is resourceful because i'm
always like even through like tough
times
even when things are hard i'm trying to
find the right path moving forward
instead of like regretting or looking
back right and i think that's like a
very helpful thing as an entrepreneur
and the
last but not least i would say creator
because that's my passion that's my
invocation
that's what i love doing i love creating
lior
this was great thank you very much thank
you for the inspiration best of luck
with open base i can't wait to use it
myself as an engineer
but thank you very much and stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you very much thank you for having
me of course